non-minimalists i've been a lifelong
minimalist
at heart so simplifying my life and
identifying values
has always been really easy for me um
and i only really own things that really
bring value into my life at this point
but what brings the most value also
brings a lot of agitation
and compulsion when i lose them or they
break
um this this partly has to do with a
mental illness but
you know things like hair ties t-shirts
pens um
i have favorites of those things and
i'll lose them break them and i just
you know i just can't focus so i try to
distract myself
meditate i've even considered just
removing all things that are my favorite
but the thing is when they're not broken
and lost and and whatnot
they uh they bring so much value into my
life
and uh so i'm just really torn about how
to bring
calm into my life without just getting
rid of everything i value
so here's the thing she she said she's a
lifelong minimalist
at heart and and i appreciate the
sentiment but here's what i'll say
minimalism
isn't in the heart it's in the actions
um
it's just like uh that's like saying i'm
a carpenter
at heart right but like really you're a
carpenter only if you take the actions
to build things
and minimalism is is a tool in a way and
as a minimalist i use
minimalism to to simplify my life
now i can actually i can really identify
with abby because
i have you know i have ocd i have many
of the same compulsions and she
in fact even mentioned some of the
things um
that yeah having the hair i don't have
hair ties but like
she said pins and and it's funny that we
got this question right now because just
this past week
i uh at home
got rid of all of my pins that weren't
uniform when you come into the office
here we have uniform pins
right um and it's because i have
i i have the same sort of neurotic
struggles that
that abby has here and so what i do is i
make sure
when i have multiples of something
whether it's underwear
shirts um i'm trying to think
socks yeah yeah whatever it is yeah
socks is a really good example
pins whenever i have multiples of
something i make sure they're all the
same because i know other
becks could care less if they we have
all the same
and and that does two things for me one
is i have the optimal version of what i
want
right right i don't have just well
there's a collection of hair ties or
pins or
underwear that some of this underwear is
uncomfortable i might as well hold on to
it or whatever
no no i have i have the ideal one and
then i also know
when i lose it or break it i know what
to replace it with
yeah when my underwear rips or whatever
i uh i decide you know i have to bring
more underwear back in my life i know
exactly i don't have to go out there and
and narose over which type should i get
should i try something new this time
the beauty about minimalism i remember
we talked to frank who's in our
documentary minimalism
or our netflix documentary and he
frank's a minimalist architect and uh we
were sitting on his couch in his living
room
and he said uh it took me three years to
find this couch and i couldn't find it
so i had it
built oh wow and uh uh i
the reason i did that took so much time
invested this time and effort
is so i would never have to think about
it again i'm not gonna have to replace
this
couch for the next 10 20 years because
i'm dissatisfied with it and the same
should be true
for the little things in our lives even
if it's a pin or a hair tie
or a t-shirt i have multiples of the
same thing and when they wear out or
they break or i
lose it i can just say let go of it
bring a new one in it's totally okay i
totally i totally agree man it's like
with my black t-shirts i might try a new
brand right and then maybe that new like
i'll get one of a new brand to try it
out and then all of a sudden that
becomes my favorite black t-shirt well
let's talk about that and i go and i get
multiple
versions of that black t-shirt and you
had this happen so so this is a good
example let's say they stopped making
this pin
they stopped making the the shirt that
you bought in fact well the the quality
reduced the company sort of changed
hands yeah i had to switch brands
and which is fine when the quality
reduced you were like i
i'm actively going to find a new brand
now but with the intent of
i want to find the brand that i can
continue to buy not because you have
brand loyalty
but because it makes the decision-making
process easy and you you're not going to
continue to experience decision fatigue
what abby is experiencing here right now
is excess fatigue
yeah absolutely i mean well the other
thing too man is
i it's well this experiment you did was
really interesting right you had your
favorites you had that article that you
did
when we first started the
minimalists.com this was uh back in 20
early 2011. and uh they asked you
well you know what are your favorite
things and you're like here this pair of
shoes pair of jeans
here's a shirt and then you were like
wait a minute like these are my favorite
things
i'm putting a lot of meaning on these i
wonder what it'd be like to just get rid
of these favorite things
yeah well i think that's important
because we do often
couple meaning with our our things
but the truth is our things don't have
any meaning other than the meaning we
give to them so i had my favorite shirt
then
right i had my favorite pair of allen
edmonds dress shoes
i had my favorite pair of j crew jeans
and when when that journalist asked me
or the blogger asked me
hey because it was one of those weird
things where it was like hey as a
minimalist what are your favorite things
and i'm like yeah i do have some
favorite things here's my favorite shirt
it's my favorite jeans here my favorite
shoes
and then as i was typing this up to him
and sending him pictures i'm like
well wait a minute why are these my
favorite things
well because i get more value from them
than the other things
but i realize like well wait a minute
they're just
things and because they're a fake it's a
favorite thing
if what if i got rid of it then i could
get rid of the meaning i'm giving to
these things it was an exercise in
letting go not of the things necessarily
but of the meaning and guess what new
things jumped up and became my favorites
if i were to hold on to those right now
i i highly doubt they'd still be my
favorite jeans
right or my favorite shoes yeah just be
holding on to them for no reason yeah as
almost 10 years ago something else
definitely would have taken their place
so abby we're not telling
you to get rid of your favorite things
but she did
ask she's like you know i just don't
want you know should i get rid of my
favorite things and it's like
if they're your favorite things that's
fine hold on to them but if you
if if they're causing you pain then then
maybe you want to rethink
uh how much attention you're giving
those items like
i know for me with the more i kind of
keep my thoughts going on and get
focused on one thing like i start to
nervous over it
and and i know that abby said she's got
a little bit of a mental illness so
you know my question would be is how can
i neros less
i know uh meditation definitely helps
with that for sure
but in the same token too like you want
a little friction you want a little pain
you want a little
you want a little bit of discomfort
right yeah i think so like you just
don't want things to be
super easy um but but abby it's
it's uh ultimately it's it's sunk costs
when you lose those things
yeah but you know what if you had to be
willing to let it go yeah if you've got
a favorite hair tie though abby
then buy multiple multiples of that hair
tie and get rid of the ones that aren't
your favorite yeah and it's gonna it's
gonna simplify it's gonna streamline
the the collection of things you have
and you're not gonna be worried about
losing them because you'll realize
that they are just things abby i'd love
to send you a copy of our book
it's called essential there's a whole
chapter actually if you're watching this
on youtube i think i have a copy of it
here
sean was kind enough to set these off
for us it is an essay collection
called essential and um what camera
should i hold this up to jordan this one
here all right there we go
um it is called essential it's 150
essays about
intentional living but there's an entire
chapter in here about
stuff and since you're dealing with your
stuff right now abby i think you'll find
value in that
so we'll either send you the book book
or if you like this podcast you'll
probably like
the audiobook version of that book as
well it's our longest book it's over a
six
hour audio book or if you want the ebook
version then we're happy to send that to
you as well sean if you'd reach out to
abby send her a copy of essential essays
by the minimalists